why are you talking to the police
without a lawyer present
ah
that's a lot of is gonna drive me insane
law order is back baby i grew up with
law order i love law and order and i was
very sad when it got canceled it's been
off the air for over a decade a decade
and why would you cancel regular law
order it was a tent pole why it was a
tent pole a tent pole i'm super happy
that it's back
though i don't know if it holds up but
let's get to it let's dig in two
separate yet equally important groups
the police who investigate crime and the
district attorneys who prosecute the
offenders these are their stories
diane i spent three years two months and
11 days in prison for a crime that i did
not commit
like many people of color
i was wrongfully charged and wrongfully
convicted okay so
uh right off the bat we have a guy who
was a stand-in for bill cosby
and right off the bat this video is
completely demonetized
great wonderful
[Music]
over here named henry king
the singer among other things all right
so clearly it's going to be one of this
guy's victims that uh got revenge and
kill this guy this is
a classic law order just ripping it
right from the headlines and you know
just laying it out on a platter here is
is my guess where this is gonna go
[Music]
all right law order's back i love it mrs
king where were you tonight between the
hours of nine and 11. okay so this is
this is the widow
uh she's clearly a suspect why doesn't
she have a lawyer have a lawyer if the
police are talking and their first
question is where were you they're
asking to find inculpatory evidence
you can afford a lawyer get a lawyer
yeah since your husband was released
from prison have there been any problems
have you noticed anything unusual i
think this is unusual that you're
talking to the police without a lawyer
present just found a text on king's
phone sent two days ago
it says it's over i'm coming for you
all right so in classic law order
fashion this is going to be a hot lead
that turns out to be a red herring i
guarantee it
hey hey how you doing
we're looking for a guy named shabazz
walker seen him
yeah yo yo i'm not done talking to you
kiss my ass
what you say to me
oh okay all right now come on there are
circumstances where the police can
detain you but this guy isn't a suspect
this isn't even a material witness this
is some random person that this guy has
found on the street and now the police
are laying hands on this guy that's
that's clearly a constitutional
violation here
are you kidding me
this young kid i got no respect oh so he
disrespected you and you just grabbed
him you don't get to do that police man
uh burn notice guy
it's like a free pass not sure what you
mean but uh uh i mean i'm white he's
black i say the wrong thing and my
career is over yeah maybe maybe is there
another way of looking at this hey frank
you came at him hot came at him hot
he laid hands on him he restricted you
that's that's assault it's more than
coming in hot if we're going to keep
this thing going you got to know
something about me
i speak my mind
probably about things i shouldn't speak
my mind about but it's just how i'm
wired i mean that's just good writing
right there
uh just replacing all the subtext with
with text uh i i speak my mind
probably about things i shouldn't speak
my mind about i mean that's uh that's
just you know a plus
look at this i know her
she's a prosecutor her name's jamie ross
henry king has been harassing me since
he was released from prison blames me
for ruining his life hmm
why you i was a lead prosecutor on his
rape trial i was also the one who made
the original promise not why are you
talking to the police without a lawyer
president i mean sure it would look a
little weird if a district attorney
asked for their own
attorney but still
you know you don't want to talk to the
police if you have
potentially some involvement in a
criminal homicide at the time there was
only one victim nicole and it was a
tough case there wasn't a lot of
evidence so i offered him immunity for
that one case so that nicole's lawyer
could depose him so you're the reason he
went to prison and the reason he was
released all right this is really
interesting see this actually did happen
in the bill cosby prosecution uh the
prosecuting attorney
made a statement that they weren't going
to
prosecute cosby and then later on due
process grounds he was able to get out
of prison after three years claiming
that he relied on the statements of the
prosecution interesting fact the
prosecutor at the time was bruce castor
jr who would go on to represent former
president trump in his impeachment
hearings but
basically and a lot of people disagree
with this
the
statements of the prosecutor were the
reason that bill cosby was let out of
jail and so we're basically copying that
fact circumstance in this prosecution as
well why did you and henry king meet the
other day he said he was going to
destroy me destroy my family and i
i just lost it and because of your
mistake
he's walking out of jail a free man
what are you really asking me detective
if i killed henry king
did you
get the hell out of my office
oh she doesn't answer the question there
and also did not have legal
representation if you're talking to the
police get legal representation hey you
got a hit here's king's wife on the
corner of 78th and columbus two blocks
from her house timestamp says 9
that's 27 minutes before henry got
popped
i didn't lie i just left out a few
details that's what lawyers would call a
distinction without a difference after
dinner i started walking home but i knew
henry would still be awake and i
couldn't bear it so i went to a bar a
block away maxwell's had a few drinks
okay
so without a lawyer you are admitting
that what you told the police previously
was a lie and now you are also saying
that you have uh animosity towards the
victim um yeah not uh not the brightest
on this one
this is probably nothing but i
did notice someone hanging out at the
end of the block a few times he had on a
hoodie
green i think
and he was wearing sunglasses even
though it was dark okay
so she she was drinking she left out a
bunch of details and then she's able to
remember a mundane fact like there was a
person with a hoodie
on the night of the murder i mean it's
kind of like the simpsons episode where
they ask you remember a boy with a piece
of paper like yeah you don't you don't
forget a fact like that when milhouse
left did you notice if he was carrying a
piece of paper oh yeah you don't forget
a thing like that
we got a hit from the dna
a woman named nicole bell uh maiden name
nicole atkins wait okay
is this like the next day the next week
is this months
surely you can't get a dna match
just like
immediately and even then
you know is this person going to be in
the database i mean
uh that this seems like some real csi
nonsense right here nicole atkins was
the first woman to accuse henry king oh
called it it's one of the victims
committed the murder nailed it tuesday
night
i was home with my husband why are you
talking to the police without a lawyer
present
ah
that's a lot of order's gonna drive me
insane no one in this building thinks he
did anything wrong hell for up to me i
give you the key to the city the other
thing you gotta understand is we've got
the whole thing on video
yeah holding the sig 380
waiting outside the service entrance
shooting king okay so
uh the police are allowed to lie to you
this has gone up to the supreme court
many times and the supreme court says
that the police are under no obligation
to tell you the truth it's popular
belief that the you know the police have
to tell you that they're police and they
can't lie to you that's total nonsense
the police can lie to you all that they
want so uh what he's doing here passes
constitutional muster
we already know what happened
why are we even talking
cause they're lying to you and you don't
have a lawyer dummy tell us your side of
the story so we can help you
then what
nicole you move on with your life
i give you my word
again it's probably getting close to the
line but i don't think that that
violates any constitutional issues here
well you saw his tv interview right
there was no remorse none it was like he
was mocking us
i uh i couldn't take it yeah and then
she confesses okay yes i shot him
nicole bell you're under arrest from
murder what
okay
and of course right she's surprised
because she's being arrested after she
confessed to the crime now you might be
wondering uh
was she given her miranda rights before
this interrogation and the answer is
probably no because the police are just
doing an investigation miranda rights
kick in only when you are dealing with
what's called a custodial interrogation
meaning that you have already been
arrested so generally when someone is
arrested they are read their miranda
rights at the same time but if the
police are interviewing you and they
haven't arrested you you're free to go
then you're not in police custody and
the police can still use your confession
against you even if you haven't gotten
miranda rights at that point presumably
we don't know exactly what happened in
this investigation but that's the way
that they're portraying it so i don't
think the lack of miranda rights at this
particular time is an issue with respect
to this this confession
keller filed a motion to suppress nicole
bell's confession
what basis defendant wasn't properly
mirandized confession wasn't known
involuntary police use improper and
coercive tactics
did cosgrove lie
yeah
did a good job too yeah who cares well i
mean
morally whatever but like
why does this district attorney care
whether the interrogating police officer
lied or not this case is front page news
no one i get it but with all due respect
that's not relevant
when you asked me to come here you said
i need someone
who sees the world through a different
lens the district attorney is recruiting
specific
uh assistant district attorneys to like
see things through a different lens
what is that nonsense no way but it's a
legal confession nolan cops
are allowed to lie they are
but it makes the confession less
reliable why
no it does no
no
like what version of ethics are they
going to go with here that a
constitutional legal method of
interrogation that got them the
confession
was
so what it was used no way i don't buy
this for a second cosgrove spun the
suspect upside down he practically
promised her immunity told her that no
one in the da's office would even
consider prosecuting her why let the
defense tear him apart on cross shift
the focus away from the evidence and on
to her sympathetic client and the big
bad police department i just want to do
what is best for this case no that is
that is uh that's so wrong
okay then it's out
how
thank you
i mean if if he's not going to use the
confession then you assign another
assistant district attorney to prosecute
this case you know just yank him off
okay so this is february
two months after the murder they're
going to trial
that's that's not a thing that that just
doesn't happen no way two blocks from
the brownstone
tossing the murder weapon into a
dumpster as promotive
well she's got a good one when the
justice system failed her the defendants
took matters into her own hands
got justice her way i mean that's that's
a classic uh opening statement you know
you can't make an argument but you need
to explain that just because
the the victim of the murder
did some bad things that that doesn't
entitle the
defendant to take law into her own hands
and you know you need to
set that out right in front of the jury
so he's doing an okay job i think you
could do a better job of it but you 100
would want to get that out in the open
and just own it from the very beginning
where did you recover the murder weapon
there ect found it in that dumpster
detective you have no idea that the
hoodie you recovered
is the actual hoodie that the person in
the photo is wearing you have no idea no
that is a that's a really bad question
you would never ever phrase
a question that way because
that's not what the witness is saying
correct whoa what you're
what are you talking about yes you have
an idea because you can use your eyes
and you can see the one that's in the
photo and you can compare it to the one
that's in court and they look really
similar so
that's uh that's a really dumb question
to ask and that's a really dumb way to
answer that question okay so help me out
here
if someone is wearing a sweatshirt and
shoots a man five times at close range
they would likely be blood spatter all
over it correct not necessarily and like
i said when we found the hoodie it was
damp like she just washed it but
ah man so the classic
blunder in cross-examination is you're
trying to get the witness to agree to
your conclusions you just lay the
foundation
this hoodie did not have any blood on it
and then you with an expert witness
later on you would have them testify
that if someone was shot at close range
that the blood would get on a hoodie and
then you connect those dots later on you
don't try and do it through an adverse
witness this is bad you have absolutely
no evidence that nicole bell committed
this crime just some random blood-free
hoodie that vaguely resembles the hoodie
no that the person
the woman in that green hoodie by that
dumpster is nicole bell detective please
refrain from drawing conclusions i
apologize your honor i'm not drawing
conclusions because the defendant
actually told me she tossed the murder
weapon into that dumpster when she
confessed that she shot and rekin
sustained
cancel my chambers now
so what the hell is going on here price
as i said your honor detective cosgrove
made an honest mistake i know cosgrove
he's smart he doesn't make honest
mistakes whatever he said he said for a
reason it's possible
it's still my fault i should have
reminded cosgrove that the confession
was inadmissible i apologize but his
testimony wasn't overly prejudicial a
curative instruction can fix this
ah
that seems
that seems unlikely i mean what he's
asking for is the judge to instruct the
jury to forget
and disregard that they heard this talk
about confession uh but it's that seems
awfully prejudicial but the thing is
this confession
was was not illegally obtained so even
if you decided as the prosecutor not to
introduce this evidence
i don't think you would ever make an
agreement with the defense that would
tie your hands in case something like
this happened i agree yeah i'll advise
the jury to disregard cosgrove's
statement what
no mistrial
the jury cannot unhear what cosgrove
just said they'll have to
because we're moving forward
the problem is
it's grounds for appeal so i would not
want to continue prosecuting this case
knowing that the court of appeals might
just turn it around like that because of
this prejudicial information that came
out he poured me a glass of wine
and i just stared at it i was afraid he
might have put something in it he saw
that i was nervous and that infuriated
him he he started
berating me so i ran outside he followed
me grabbed me i thought he was going to
kill me so i shot him
henry king ruined my life he ruined 39
other lives too
and some judge just let him walk free
objection she's making a speech so i
shot him so
i mean
making a speech that's not
not an objection i guess he's saying
she's lapsing into a narrative but like
you don't
you don't make that objection when the
you know this kind of a witness is
testifying did the defendant
tell you she'd planned to kill henry
king
i refuse to answer on the grounds that
it may incriminate me
okay so this would cause all kinds of
problems with the the trial here i mean
obviously you're not allowed to
use
someone's uh
statement that they refuse to testify
against themselves i just don't know if
that applies to third parties or if the
jury can take an adverse inference given
that some witness is refusing to testify
on the grounds that it might incriminate
them yeah this is a disaster for the
defense this is just really really bad i
don't think this is bad for the
prosecution at all a jury wants to
acquit irrespective of the facts
irrespective of the law
too bad we didn't have a damn confession
yeah it would have been good
you
told me a story
a while back
about your family
you're saying you want me to deliver the
closing i'm a prosecutor
i am sworn to enforce the laws of the
state
yet i understand the defendant's desire
for revenge
nine years ago my
sister was raped and murdered ah
i do
i don't think you're allowed to bring in
that kind of a personal anecdote on
closing argument
that
that seems incorrect right there when
henry king was released from prison the
defendant's thirst for revenge escalated
maybe she even began to fantasize about
killing him that's ah
that seems like an awful lot of
speculation even for closing argument
this case comes down to one simple
question
did nicole bell
intentionally shoot and kill henry king
if the answer is yes
you must convict
on the count of murder in the second
degree wait
why would it be murder in the second
degree i mean this is
this was
premeditated i mean she planned it out
and that was the
entire prosecution's argument here
really should be murder in the first
degree uh i don't think there's any like
yes it's a lesser offense but if you
prove up all of the elements of murder
one and then you go for murder two it's
going to confuse the jury that
should be murder in the first degree
guilty
[Music]
you got it right sam
doesn't feel right and now she's showing
remorse but it it was absolutely the
right decision they would have used the
confession and they would have no
problem about this conviction it's uh
this is this is weird this is silly
the only thing that will let me sleep is
you requesting the lightest sentence
possible
no
never
okay well at least law and order is back
now it's time to give it a grade for
legal realism on the one hand uh you
have basically a case that parallels the
bill cosby case issues involving
immunity lying to the victim and the
constitutional issues that come as a
result of that
on the other hand uh basically
everyone's motivation makes no sense the
strategy makes no sense and uh none of
this would ever happen because the da's
would not have moral issues with any of
this so on the whole uh god i it pains
me but i have to say this is probably
c or c minus i'm thrilled that law order
is back but this was terribly
unrealistic
and apropos of this episode there's been
a lot of discussion about the potential
to end roe versus wade and it often
feels like there's nothing that we can
do but that's not true in fact if you
want to do some good for this world i'd
recommend tab for cause which lets you
raise money for charity just by opening
tabs and browsing the internet which
you're probably going to do anyway and
tab for causes responded to your request
and they just launched tab for
reproductive health every tab that you
open in your browser will raise money
for non-profit organizations protecting
and providing access to reproductive
health care like the center for
reproductive rights and planned
parenthood and tab for cause is great i
use it myself it's a google chrome
extension that allows you to pick the
charity of your choice and then every
time you open up a new tab instead of a
blank page it displays a new
customizable tab with a couple of tiny
ads and the money that you generate is
then donated to your charity you can
even customize a new tab that opens up
in your browser and in fact legal eagle
tabbers have raised over thirty five
thousand dollars for charity and i know
this because tab for causes finances are
100 transparent you can see for yourself
how much they've raised and where it has
gone all you have to do is click on the
link that's on screen right now or in
the description to install this browser
extension that's it every page that you
then open will create revenue that goes
to charity so just click on the link
that's on screen it's the easiest way to
donate to charity and you can even just
sit there and open up a bunch of tabs
for fun so just click on the link below
to download the extension and do some
good by doing what you were going to do
anyway so click on that link or i'll see
you in court